[موسيقى]
اسعدتم اوقات الاعزاء المشاهدين ان صهيب
احييكم وهذه التاسعه هذا المساء
نتنياهو يطلبوا من امريكا واوروبا تغيير
نهجها مع ايران واوستون يؤكد على دعم
اسرائيل بمواجهه طهران
امريكا تفرض عقوبات على شبكه صرافه تعمل
بالظل تنقل مليارات الدولارات للنظام
الايراني
[تصفيق]
البيت الابيض يكشف سبب وجود طيارين
اوكرانيين في واشنطن ندرس تركيب اسلحه
امريكيه على مقاتلاتهم الروسيه
في هذه النقطه الحدوديه في مدينه
كاليشماليه فرنسا كان المهاجرون ينتظرون
حلم العبور الى بريطانيا داخل خيام جاءت
الشرطه وقتلعتها ووضعت العربيه ترصد
عمليات الهجره غير المشروعه بين فرنسا
وبريطانيا على بحر المانش
[موسيقى]
اكد وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلينت انه الا يتم
السماح لايران بالحصول على سلاح نووي وقال
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي لنظره الامريكي
اثناء اللقاء الذي جمعهما في تل ابيب ان
عليهم الاستعداد سويا لاي عمل محتمل ضد
ايران كما تحدث لوين من جهته على تركيز
المحادثات مع نظيره الاسرائيلي على
التهديدات الايرانيه واكد اوستن التزام
واشنطن بامن اسرائيل بشكل قوي وان
المساعدات العسكريه لاسرائيل ستبقى عند
مستوياتها
الولايات المتحده ملتزمه بامر اسرائيل
وسنستمر في ذلك الرئيس بايدن اكد خلال
زيارته لاسرائيل على قوه الروابط بين
شعبينا واسرائيل شريك مهم للولايات
المتحده نعمل مع اسرائيل وندعمها في ضمان
امنها كما نشعر بقلق بالغ من زياده ايران
لتخصيب اليورانيوم وتهديد امن المنطقه من
خلال دعمها للارهاب ونعمل على منعها من
امتلاك سلاح النووي كذلك الولايات المتحده
قالقه ايضا من عنف المستوطنين ضد
الفلسطينيين بشكل خاص
قبل ذلك شدد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
بنيامين نتنياهو على ضروره تبني نهج حازم
ضد ايران وقال ان من يعتقد ان ايران ستترك
للحصول على سلاح نووي مخطئ واشار الى ان
اجنده المشتركه بين اسرائيل وامريكا لمنع
ايران من امتلاك سلاح النووي
لدينا اجنده مشتركه لمنع ايران من امتلاك
السلاح النووي والتصدي لاي عدوان قد تشنه
طهران للحفاظ على امن وازدهار المنطقه
والسعي لتوسيع دائره السلام
معنى مباشره من القدس زياد حلبي مراسل
العربيه زياد اهلا بك معنا كيف فسر كلام
وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي وزير الدفاع
الامريكي وايضا رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي
في اسرائيل عمليه هناك فهم بان ثمه توافقا
بين اسرائيل والولايات المتحده على الهدف
اي منع ايران من امتلاك سلاح نووي ولكن ثم
اختلاف وخلافات حول الاسلوب للتواصل الى
ذلك
الاسرائليون يضغطون ان على الولايات
المتحده بالذات دون الدول الاخرى ان تضع
على الطاوله ما يسمى خيارا عسكريا ذا
مصداقيه يقنع ايران بان هذا الخيار قد
يفعل ضدها فيما اذا استمرت في سعيها
للتوصل الى قنبله نوويه اي الى قدره نوويه
عسكريه فيما ان اوستن ابلغ اسرائيل اليوم
مره ثانيه بان خيار اداره بايدن يبقى
الدبلوماسيه وليس العمل العسكري طلب في
الكواليس ايضا من اسرائيل عدم مفاجاه
واشنطن في عمل ضد الطيران بدون التنسيق
معها او ابلاغها لان ذلك يمكن له ان يؤدي
الى استهداف المصالح الامريكيه في المنطقه
من قبل ايران بهذا المعنى كما قلنا هناك
تحديد للهدف منع ايران نوويه ولكن اختلاف
كبير نسبيا حول اسلوب التوصل الى ذلك نعم
طيب اذا هذا هو السبب وراء زياره الى
اسرائيل زياد انه لا ضوء اخضر امريكي حتى
الان لاسرائيل لضرب ايران
هذا جزء من اهداف الزياره بالفعل هو
الضغط على اسرائيل بانه عليها ان لا تفاجئ
الامريكيين في موضوع ايران لكن ليس هذا جل
ما كان في الزياره هذا الموضوع طرح حتى
ثالثا في المناقشات اوستن اهتم عبر عن
قلقه في ثلاثه مواضيع الموضوع الاول هو ما
يحدث في الاراضي الفلسطينيه من انفجار طلب
من اسرائيل اتخاذ اجراءات فوريه لمنع
اعتداءات المستوطنين وانفجار الوضع
بالكامل في الاراضي الفلسطينيه الامر
الاخر ما يحدث داخل اسرائيل من انقلاب على
النظام القضائي يقلق الامريكيين اوضح بان
امريكا لا تستطيع ان تدافع عن اسرائيل في
المحافل الدوليه بسبب هذا الموضوع وثالثا
وكان موضوعيا في ذلك ويتفق مع
الاسرائيليين القلق بشان ايران نوويه نعم
طيب زياده على ذكر هذه الاحتجاجات داخل
اسرائيل يبدو انها اثرت حتى على زياره
لورد اوستن يبدو ان الوزير وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لم يغادر مطار تل ابيب
هذا صحيح هو حوصر تماما في المطار ومنذ
البدايه اوضح للاسرائيليين بانه لن يخرج
من هناك اللقاءات جرت في المطار وصل
نتنياهو الى المطار عبر مروحيه لانه لم
يتمكن وحتى موه عمليا ارسل مروحيه عسكريه
في وقت سابق ومن ثم في مروحيه شرطه هو
وزوجته وصل الى المطار والتقايق والتقى
اوستن هناك قبل الذهاب الى روما وكذا فعل
وزير الدفاع ايضا بسبب الاحتجاجات الشديده
عمليا هناك الان نوع من القلق الامريكي
حتى من هذا الموضوع ان يقدم نتنياهو على
عمل عسكري بسبب ما يحدث في اسرائيل اللافت
كان بان الاعلان لم يتحدث تقريبا في
اسرائيل عن زياره اوستن بكلمه كل ما كانت
اليوم في الاعلام الاسرائيلي هو فقط
الاحتجاجات
زياد حلبي مباشره من القدس
وكما ذكر زياد وبالتزامن مع زياره اوستن
خرجت تظاهرات حشده في اسرائيل احتجاجا على
خطه حكومه نتنياهو لتغيير النظام القضائي
واشارت مراسله العربيه الى ان 60 الفا من
المتظاهرين تجمعوا بالتزامن مع وصول وزير
الدفاع الامريكي الى اسرائيل واغلق
المتظاهرون الطرق السريعه المؤديه الى
المطار قبل مغادره نتنياهو الى روما
[موسيقى]
نحن هنا نتواجد في مطار بن غريون الدولي
حيث يتواجد عشرات المتظاهرين الغاضبين
الذين يحاولون منع الرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو من السفر الى
ايطاليا بسبب ما يعرف بتغيير نظام القضائي
وقاموا بعرقله حركه السير داخل شوارع
المطار بعد مراوغه قوات الامن التي سمحت
لهم بالدخول ظنا انهم من المسافرين لم
تعرف لهذه المظاهرات فقط رحله 60 الف
اسرائيلي سيسافرون من مطار بن غوريون
اليوم انما عرقلت زياره وزير الدفاع
الامريكي
مرتين الى اسرائيل حيث قرر اجراء اللقاءات
مع صانعي القرار قرب المطار دون الدخول
الى البلاد ومن المتوقع ان تستمر هذه
المظاهرات طالما ان الحكومه مستمره في
الانقلاب على القضاء لا نقول غاصي في
المطار بن غريون العربيه
[موسيقى]
فرضت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات على
ايران هي الثانيه خلال يومين وشملت
العقوبات الجديده 39 فردا وكيانا بما فيها
عقوبات ضد كيانات مقرها الصين وشركه تعمل
على تصنيع المسيرات وعقوبات على شبكات
مصرفيه تساهم بدخول مليارات الدولارات الى
ايران سنويا بحسب ما اوردت الوزاره
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا قطعوا شريان التمويل
الايرانيه هدف يضاهي باهميته خطوط شاحنات
اسلحتها وطريق عبورها للميليشيات كذلك حيث
فرضت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه عقوبات على
تسعه وثلاثين كيارا تساعد ايران على
التهرب من العقوبات واشنطن وصفت تلك
كيانات بشبكه ظل مصرفي التي توفر عشرات
المليارات من الدولارات للنظام الايراني
سنويا الشبكه هي واحده من عده انظمه تمويل
غير مشروعه تمنح الكيانات الايرانيه
الخاضعه للعقوبات مثل صناعه
البتروكيماويات قدره الوصول الى النظام
المالي العالمي والتعتيم على تجارتهم مع
العملاء الاجانب وكانت الولايات المتحده
اضافت الى قائمه العقوبات امس مسؤولين
ايرانيين وشركات على خلفيه اتهامات
بارتكاب انتهاكات جسيمه لحقوق الانسان
يذكر مشاهدينا ان نظام الظل المصرفي هو
مجموعه من الوسطاء الماليين غير المصرفيين
الذين يقدمون خدمات مماثله للبنوك
التجاريه التقليديه
[موسيقى]
وتعليقا على هذه العقوبات هكذا وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه
على النظام الايراني وتعطيل شبكات تمويله
وذلك بعد ان فرضت الخزانه الامريكيه
عقوبات على ما وصفته بشبكه ظل المصرفيه
المكونه من 39 كيانا والتي تسهل انشطه
ايران للتهرب من العقوبات
بعد قليل في التاسعه
سيده اوكرانيا الاولى تزور مبنى قناه
العربيه في دبي
اهلا بكم من جديد نستكمل التاسعه هذا
المساء من الملف الاوكراني حيث اكدت
واشنطن وجود طيارين اوكرانيين في قاعده
جويه امريكيه في ولايه اريزونا هدفه ليس
تدريبهم على قياده طائرات الاف 16 وانما
تقييم امكانيه نصب صواريخ امريكيه على
مقاتله
منسق الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في مجلس
الامن القومي بالبيت الابيض جون كيربي في
حديث لسي ان ان الهدف ليست تدريب وانما
تقييم لامكانيه استخدام انواع معينه من
الاسلحه الامريكيه على مقاتلاتهم اي على
طائرات ميج
هذا واكد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير
فيصل بن فرحان ان الاولويه بالنسبه
للمملكه حاليا في اليمن هي الوصول لوقف
اطلاق نار دائم ثم اطلاقي عمليه سياسيه
مشيرا في مؤتمر صحفي مع نظره الروسي الى
ان الحوار جيرن للعمل في هذا المسار
الاولويه الان هي وقف اطلاق نار ومن ثم
اطلاق الحوار خلاف ذلك لا اريد ان اخوض في
اي تفاصيل تاكيدا او نفيا لانها ليس مفيدا
لبصارات المفاوضات لكن وقت نؤكد ان اهتمام
المملكه حاليا هو ايجاد سبيل لوقف القتال
بشكل دائم ومن ثم اطلاق حوار يمني
يضمن استقرار اليمن ويضمن استقلاليه اليمن
ويضمن بعد ذلك ايضا ازدهار اليمن وهذا هي
الاولويه لدينا
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان قال ان السعوديه جاهزه للقيام بما
يلزم لحل الصراع في اوكرانيا وفي رده على
سؤال لمراسله العربيه اكد الامير فيصل بن
فرحان ان السعوديه تواصل العمل لانهاء
النزاع بين روسيا واوكرانيا نسعى دائما
لدعم كل ما من شانه
الوصول الى تسويه لهذا الصراع ونحن جاهزون
للعمل مع الاطراف
للبحث عن الحلول السلميه وقد سبق انساهمنا
فيما
حصل في من تبادل السجناء
والذي اشرف عليهم ولا العهد مباشره بتعاون
مشكور من الجانب الروسي
وسفنستمر في البحث عن الفرص المتاحه
لتسهيل الحوار بين الطرفين
من جهته قال وزير الخارجيه الروسيه
للعربيه ان موقفها السعوديه من الازمه
الاوكرانيه ليس محدودا بتبادل الاسرى وان
موسكو تؤكد حرصها على التعاون مع السعوديه
في كل المجالات مدروس تطرقنا لمناقشه عده
قضايا في الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا
موسكو والرياض متفقتان على ان الحل
السياسي هو الافضل لكل القضايا العالميه
بمشاركه جميع الاطراف نحن نقدر عمل
اصدقائنا في السعوديه والدور الذي تلعبه
المملكه في المنطقه
معنى من موسكو ومراسلتنا كاتيا طعمه كاتيا
اهلا بك معنا هل من ردود افعال اخرى حتى
الان عن الوساطه السعوديه
للسلام بين الروس والاوكرانيين
مرحبا صهيب بالفعل الزياره اليوم ولقاء
وزير الخارجيه السعودي نظيره الروسي في
موسكو كان لها اصداء ايجابيه في روسيا
طبعا اولا ابتداء من الدور التي تلعبه
المملكه في عمليه الوساطه وبالاخص عمليه
الوساطه في تبادل عمليه تبادل الاسرى بين
روسيا واوكرانيا وهذا ما اشاد به وزير
الخارجيه الروسيس الذي قال ان المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ودول العربيه اخرى تلعب
دورا هاما في هذه العمليه وان للمملكه ليس
فقط دور في عمليه تبادل الاسرى والملف
الانساني في الازمه الاوكرانيه ولها ادوار
اخرى طبعا هو تحدث عن خيارات قد تلعبها
المملكه كوسيط لحل الازمه الاوكرانيه ولكن
الرفض من الجانب الاوكراني لاجراء مباحثات
بعد توقيع وزير عفوا الرئيس الاوكراني
زينينسكي لقانون يمنع اجراء اي مباحثات مع
روسيا هو ما يق
التسويه السلميه للازمه الاوكرانيه
والايقاف طبعا العمليه العسكريه وبدا من
مباحثات وفقا للشروط الروسيه طبعا كما
ذكرت لك
الزياره هذه الايجابيه وبالاخص انها روسيا
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه متفقان في صيغه
اوبك بلوس طبعا للنفط كان هذا ما تحدث
ايضا عنه وزير الخارجيه الروسيه الذي قال
ان هناك توافق في في التنسيق بين موسكو
وبين الرياض من جانب ومن جانب اخر اكد انه
لن يؤثر اي شيء على العمل في صيغه صيغه
فلوس للنفذ حافظ هذا كامل سعودي
طبعا
والتفاهمات كذلك الملاحظ ان السعوديه
موقفها ايضا على مسافه واحده رغم التوافق
والمصالح المشتركه مع روسيا فيما يتعلق
بلس على مسافه واحده من الاوكرانيين ايضا
قبل فتره كان هناك زياره لاوكرانيا والتقى
فيها وزير الخارجيه السعودي الرئيسي
لانسكي وكبار المسؤولين الاوكرانيين واعلن
عن حزمه مساعدات كذلك لاوكرانيا كيف
ينظر روسيا الى اين يمكن ان تصل الوساطه
السعوديه بين الطرفين بحكم هذه العلاقه مع
الجانبين
صحيح صهيب هذا ما وصفه
اليوم ان الموقف السعودي هو موقف متوازن
من الازمه الاوكرانيه وهذا ما اشاد به
ايضا طبعا زياره وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الى موسكو هي تاتي بعد زيارته السابقه الى
اوكرانيا وهذا قد يعطي دلالات كما تحدث
بعد الخبراء على امكانيه لعب ان تلعب
المملكه العربيه السعوديه دورا ما في
عمليه الحلحله او عمليه حل الازمه
الاوكرانيه وهذا طبعا ما اكد ايضا عليه
وزير الخارجيه الروسيه اليوم الذي قال ان
المملكه لا تلعب دورا فقط في الملف
الانساني ولكنها ايضا قادره او تستطيع ان
تلعب دورا اخر في الملفات الاخرى في
الازمه
الاوكرانيه لذلك كما تحدث الخبراء قد يكون
للمملكه
الخاصه على بعد هذه التهتين الزيارتين
التاثيرا على الجانبين بان تدفعهما نحو
الجلوس الى طاوره المباحثات طبعا
كما تحدث بعض الخبراء طبعا صهيب كانت يا
طعمه مباشره من موسكو
مشاهدينا قبل ان نتابع مع الميدانيات في
الحرب نتوقف مع هذه الاخبار العاجل التي
وردت قبل قليل الازمه تشتد في اسرائيل على
ما يبدو الرئيس الاسرائيلي في خطاب دعا
نتنياهو الى التراجع عن الاصلاحات
القضائيه التي ينوي
اقرارها طبعا في ظل المظاهرات العانمه
التي تخرج في اسرائيل وخرجت اليوم لدرجه
كما تبعنا قبل قليل مع مراسلنا في القدس
وزيره الدفاع الامريكي لم يغادر مطار بن
غوريون بسبب كثافه الاحتجاجات في اسرائيل
اذا الرئيس الاسرائيلي يدعو نتنياهو
للتراجع عن هذه التعديلات القضائيه
بالعوده الى ميدانيات الحرب ومع اشتداد
المعارك على الارض والخسائر البشريه التي
يتكبدها الطرفان في الحرب باتت التعبئه
العسكريه ازمه ظهرت في روسيا ثم انها
انتقلت يبدو انها انتقلت الى اوكرانيا
الان لاسيما مع عدم وجود امال بانهاء
الصراع في المستقبل المنظور
مجله الايكونوميست مع اشتداد المعارك في
شرقي اوكرانيا كثفت كييف انشطه التعبئه
العسكريه في الشهرين الاولين من 2023
الجيش الاوكراني يحتاج الى مزيد من القوات
لمواكبه المعارك وتدفق الاسلحه التي
يقدمها الغرب
نيوزويك خدمه الامن الاوكرانيه حجبت 26
قناه على تيليجرام يعتقد انها تساعد من هم
في سن التجنيد على تجنب التعبئه
نيوزويك ماركات جامعه جورج مصر
استراتيجيه اوكرانيا الان تكمن في استدعاء
اكبر عدد من المجندين للتعبئه مع استمرار
الحرب
مجله الوضع في اوكرانيا سبقه الامر نفسه
في روسيا التي استدعت 300 الف جندي سابق
في سبتمبر 2022
فرار اكثر من 300 وسبعين الف روسي من
البلاد في الاسبوعين اللذين اعقب مرسوم
بوتين للتعبئه
فيما وصف بالانتصار القضائي النادره
للكرملين رفعت محكمه العدل التابعه
للاتحاد الاوروبي العقوبات عن والده مؤسس
فاجنريام
المحكمه استبعدت فيوليتا بريكوجينا
البالغه من العمر 37 عاما من قائمه عقوبات
على مستوى الاتحاد الاوروبي متدرعه بانه
لا ذنب للوالده المسنه في انخراط ابنها
بالحرب الى جانب بوتين وصفه ذلك بغير
العاتق وكانت والده مؤسس فاجنر اضيفت
للقائمه بعد بديل عمليه العسكريه الروسيه
في اوكرانيا بصفتها المالكه الاسميه
للعديد من الشركات التي لها صلات بابنها
قالت المخابرات الامريكيه في التقرير
السنوي لتقييم التهديدات الناروسيا لا
تريد صراعا مباشرا مع الولايات المتحده
والنيتو لكن ذلك قد يحدث واشارت المخابرات
الامريكيه الى ان روسيا غير قادره على
الاستمرار في حربها باوكرانيا بدون دعم
عسكري من دول اخرى
في الاثناء قال رئيس المخابرات العسكريه
الليتوانيه ان روسيا لديها ما يكفي من
موارد لمواصله الحرب في اوكرانيا لعامين
واشار الى ان الموارد التي تمتلكها روسيا
في الوقت الحالي ستكون كافيه لمواصله
الحرب بنفس الوتيره لمده عامين مضيفا ان
طول الفتره التي يمكن لروسيا فيها شنوا
الحرب يعتمد ايضا على الدعم الذي يتلقاه
الجيش الروسي من دول مثل ايران وكوريا
الشماليه
بما يشبه احتجاجات صامته على الحرب
الروسيه في اوكرانيا مجموعه من الروس
يقيمون معرضا سريا في محطه الالحافلات
بمدينه
روسيا المعرض لم يروج له على مواقع
الانترنت وهو يقام ليلا فقط
ويمنع زائروه من استخدام الهواتف وبدا
المعرض بداه فنانون اعتقلوا بسبب احتجاجهم
على الحرب او استولت الشرطه على اعمالهم
في معارض اخرى هناك يمكن مشاهده الفن
الروسي المعارض للحرب وما تشمله من صور
قاتمه ودمويه للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين
ومدافن صغيره
عبر البحر بدات ايراننا بشن او بشحن اطنان
من الاسلحه لروسيا وفقا لمصادر امنيه
غربيه استندت على صور لاقمار صناعيه توثق
العمليه شبكه سكاي نيوز البريطانيه نقلت
عن المصدر الامنيه الغربيه قولها ان
سفينتي الشحن العموميتين المزعوم تورطهما
في نقل الذخيره من ايران الى روسيا يطلق
عليهما موسى جليل
وبه مضيفا ان السفينتان كانتا ترفعان
العلم الروسي
وغادرتا ميناء امير اباد الايراني متجهتين
الى روسيا عبر بحر قزوين ووفقا لمعلومات
المصدر الامني وصور الاقمار الصناعيه فان
السفينتان تحملان نحو 100 فان السفينتين
عفوا اذا تحملان نحو 100 مليون قطعه ذخيره
بهدف تجديد مخزوناتها على خط المواجهه في
اوكرانيا وهذه الذخيره خاصه
خاصه بقذفات الصواريخ وقذائف الهاون
والمدافع الرشاشه
وصواريخ صغيره للمسيرات هو رصاص المسدسات
الكلاشنكوف مضيفا ان موسكو دفعت ثمن هذه
الذخيره نقطا مشاهدينا هذه المساعدات تاتي
على راس المساعدات السابقه والتي قدمتها
طهران حيث زودت موسكو بمئات من الطائرات
من دون طيار القاتله والتي لعبت دورا في
محاولات تدمير البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في
اوكرانيا وفقا الاتهامات الغرب طبعا
[موسيقى]
زارت السيده الاوكرانيه الاولى اولينا
زيلينسكا زوجه رئيس الاوكراني
قناه العربيه في دبي اليوم واجرت سيده
اوكرانيا الاولى جوله في جميع الاقسام
اضافه الى مقابله سيتم بثها لاحقا علما
بان السيده الاولى موجوده في دوله
الامارات حتى العاشر من مارسا الحالي
للمشاركه في النسخه الثانيه من قمه فورس
التي تستضيفها ابو ظبي
[موسيقى]
اهتمام وثيق تليه تليه كبرى العقول
العسكريه مشاهدينا في الصين للعمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا فمنها نتعلم
الدروس
وتحول نقاط الضعف لمكان قوه
مشاهدينا الجيش الصيني ورغم كونه الاكبر
في العالم مع
خدمه نحو مليوني جندي بصفوفه الا انه لم
يتم اختباره الى حد كبير وكانت اخر حروبه
فاشله في فيتنام عام 79
وبمراقبه كل منعطف للحرب مشاهدينا استخلص
القاده الصينيون سبعه دروس من التجربه
الروسيه اخطاء تتجنبها الصين ان قررت غزو
تايوان الدرس الاول مشاهدينا يتمثل بايجاد
طرق لاسقاط شبكه ستار لينك للانترنت او
تعطيلها فهذه الشبكه مكنت القوات
الاوكرانيه من التواصل بشكل امن
واستخدمتها عسكريا بالسيطره على المسيرات
اما الدرس الثاني مشاهدينا فهو تعزيز قدره
الصين على الدفاع عن دباباتها ومدرعاتها
وسفنها الحربيه من الاف الاسلحه المتطوره
المحموله على الكتف بما فيها صواريخ
جافلين فيما قلل القاده من اهميه منظومه
رابطين نجاحها في اوكرانيا بامداد
المعلومات عبر اما رابع المكتسبات الصينيه
من تجربه روسيا فتتمثل بمهاجمه الذيل
اللوجستيه للدبابات الروسيه اي شاحنات
الوقود والذخيره على الصين مشاهدينا ايضا
الاستثمار اكثر في تطوير المسيرات وضمان
هيكل قياده موحد وتنسيق والاتصال مع قاده
ذوي رتب منخفضه في الميدان توقع عمليات
تخريبيه من داخل اراضيها كهجمات على
قافلات نقل الاسلحه والقوات واستخدام
تطبيق المراسله التليجرام لجمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه من المدنيين اما اخر
الدروس واهمها وهي التكيف مع موجات من
العقوبات الاقتصاديه الغربيه والتحضر لرد
فعل عالمي سيتبع حتما اي هجوم صيني محتمل
على تايوان
[موسيقى]
التاسعه مستمرا نتابع فيها بعد قليل
[تصفيق]
مع استمرار الاحتجاجات مخاوفوا من انعكاس
الصراع الغربي الروسيه على جورجيا
على شاشه العربيه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد كشف الرئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي ان هناك فيلما يوثق لفضاء
ارتكبها الارهابيون قد لا ينام المصريون
اذا شاهدوه
انا والله لولا رافه بيكم
اوريكم فيلم واحد
والله العظيم
انا بقسم بالله
انا انا متهيا لي كل المصريين ما هتنام لو
اذعت لكم الفيلم ده
على اللي كانوا بيعملوه وده متصور
الرئيس المصري قال ان الحرب على الارهاب
لم تكن سهله كما كشف السيسي عن موافقه
اسرائيل منذ العام 2011 على زياده القوات
المصريه في سيناء لمكافحه الارهاب
كان القرار ساعتها من
من سياده المشير ان احنا ندخل بقوات عملنا
الاجراءات المطلوبه مع
الاسرائيليين في الوقت دوت
واتصلت بيهم قلت لهم احنا محتاجين ندخل
قوات دلوقتي في المنطقه في العريش ورفح
والشيخ زويد عشان
نسيطر على الموقف هناك الحقيقه عشان ده
بسجله للتاريخ يعني ان هم كانوا متفاهمين
ده
كانوا متفاهمين ده وما كانوش يعني الحقيقه
كانوا قالوا يعني
بس ادينا خبر القوات اللي هتبقى موجوده قد
ايه
ونسقه معانا يعني
واستمرينا من الوقت دوت لغايه يمكن لغايه
دلوقتي بس يمكن حجم القوات اللي كان موجود
[موسيقى]
خلال
التمن تسع سنين دول
من 2011 لغايه النهارده
زادت القوات كل مره عشان
نتعامل مع التحديات اللي موجوده هناك
[موسيقى]
قالت الامم المتحده انها ستقوم بشراء
ناقله كبيره لتحسين لتخزين حوالي مليون
فاصل واحد برميل من النفط حيث سيجري نقلها
من النقله المتهلكه صافره روسيا قباله
السواحل اليمنيه وتاتي خطه الامم المتحده
كمحاوله لتجنب كارثه بيئيه ومن المتوقع ان
تبدا العمليه منتصف مايو القادم
تسلم السودان امراتين وثلاثه اطفال من
العائلات التابعه لتنظيم داعش من مناطق
الاداره الذاتيه وفقا لوثيقه رسميه وهذا
بين الاداره الذاتيه لشمال وشرق سوريا
والسودان وقال نائب رئاسه القوات المشتركه
روبيه البحو ان بلاده من الدول العربيه
السباقه في استعاده مواطنيها بمناطق
الاداره الذاتيه
[موسيقى]
شهدت العاصمه جورجيه تبليسي احتجاجات
جديده الليله في محيط البرلمان على الرغم
من سحب الحكومه لمشروع القانون الذي اثار
الجدل في الايام الماضيه والذي على اثره
شهدت البلاد اشتباكات عنيفه بين الشرطه
والمحتجين
اروح دلوقتي ولا اتمشى على الهواء
في وقت تحاول السلطات الجرجيه احتواء
المظاهرات المتاججه في الشارع حولت روسيا
خط هذه الازمه باتجاه الغرب تخطيطا
وتنفيضا حيث اتهم رئيس اللجنه الدستوريه
في مجلس الاتحاد الروسي اندريه
والاتحاد الاوروبي بالقيامه بانقلاب غير
دستوري في جورجيا وشدد المسؤول الروسي على
ان تغيير السلطه في البلاد يجب ان يكون من
خلال الانتخابات وليس نتيجه الثورات دمويه
تمولها الحكومات الاجنبيه وفق تعبيره
بدورها اعلنت احزاب المعارضه الجورجيه
انها ستواصل الاحتجاجات ضد الحكومه كما
طالبت بالافراج عن عشرات المحتجين
المعتقلين من قبل القوات الامنيه
[موسيقى]
من جهته يا اعلن حزب الحلم الحاكم في
جورجيا سحب نواب البرلمان مشروع قانون
العملاء الاجانب المقترح بعد ايام من
الاحتجاجات المندده به القانون الذي طرحته
الحكومه الجورجيه يحمل اسم شفافيه النفوذ
الاجنبي ويستهدف وسائل الاعلام والمنظمات
غير الحكوميه ويخشى منتقدون القانون من
استخدامه ذريعه من الحكومه لقمع المعارضه
اسوه بتشريع مماثل في روسيا
نشر الحزب الحاكم بيانا قال فيه انه مستعد
لالغاء مشروع القانون الروسي الذي اثار
الاحتجاجات في شوارع تبليسي لا نصدق هذا
البيان السياسيه لان لدينا تجربه حزينه
للغايه الحلم الجورجي كذب على الشعب عده
مرات نحن بحاجه الى طرح هذا القانون على
الجلسه البرلمانيه المكتمله والغائه بشكل
رسمي
وفي التعليقات الروسيه على ما يجري في
جورجيا عبر المتحدث باسم
عن قلقه ازاء الاضطرابات في جورجيا بعد
ليلتين من الاشتباكات العنيفه بين الشرطه
والمتظاهرين رغم عدم وجود علاقات بين
البلدين على حد وصفه
معنى من باريس الدكتور محمد سيف الدين
الباحث في العلاقات الدوليه دكتور اهلا بك
معنا هل حقا روسيا ليست لها علاقه بما
يحصل في جورجيا الان
السؤال يعني مهم جدا لناحيه علاقه روسيا
بالحزب الحاكم في في جورجيا وايضا علاقه
الغرب بالاحداث التي تجري الان في جورجيا
كنا تحدثنا قبل شهرين على ما اذكر عبر
شاشتكم عن موضوع جورج وان هناك شيئا يتحرك
من تحت هذه الصوره التي كانت هادئه في
البدايه جورجيا اذا يعني اذا كان من
المفيد ان نسترجع الاحداث صحيح الزوجه
تسير على اعلى منحدر وعلى الحرب الروسيه
على حافه ضيقه حتى حتى ما قبل ذلك منذ عام
1991 جورجيا تسير على حافه ضيقه جدا وهي
مسكونه بقلق التاريخ والعلاقات التي كانت
تجمعها وضمن الاتحاد السوفيتي وتم يعني
حاولت القياده دائما في المقاطعه ولكن
الحقيقه قبل سنه مع الحرب في اوكرانيا
استرجعت هذه الازمه كذلك بين روسيا
وجورجيا تحديدا قصه
اقليميا الجنوبيه اللذان تعتبره ما تبليسي
بانهما احتلتا من قبل روسيا هل ما يحصل
الان في جورجيا نفس الشيء ما يحصل في
اوكرانيا مع اقليم الدومباس هل هناك عوامل
تشابه ولماذا تحريك هذا الملف الان والحرب
ما زالت لم تنتهي في اوكرانيا
نعم حتى ندخل مباشره بالتفاعلات هذه
الاحداث تقبضا من الطبيعي ومن المفهوم جدا
ان ما يجري الان في جورجيا مرتبط بشكل
كبير جدا بما يجري في اوكرانيا هناك
تشابهات بين الحالتين وهناك مظاهر من
الاختلاف الاختلاف في الاساسي يظهر في
طريقه التعامل تبليسه حزب حلم جورجيا مع
هذه الاحداث ونيته بعدم الدخول في الصراع
القائم بين روسيا والغرب ومحاولته تجنيب
البلاد التفاعلات التي يمكن ان تنشا من
ذلك في المقابل مصلحه روسيا ان تحفظ حكما
في جورجيا لا ينخرط في العقوبات المواجهه
ضدها ولا ينخرط في المسار الغربي الذي
يتوجه ضدها وان يقيم علاقات جيده معها
وهذا ما يحدث الان في جورجيا مع حلم
جورجيا لكن المطروح الان من قبل المعارضه
ومن قبل الحركات التي تنشط على الارض هو
ان تستخدم جورجيا او يتم تحول جورجيا الى
التحالف الغربي والدخول في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وتشجيع هذا ثروه تنميته وهذا
خيار مطروح بشكل كبير جدا في جورجيا وله
مناصريه المتظاهرون
ورفعوا ايضا عالم الاتحاد الاوروبي في
المظاهرات امام البرلمان وهتفوا بان
القانون قانون الشفافيه الذي تسميه السلطه
بقانون الشفافيه هو القانون الروسي
هنا اريد ان اسال يعني الطرفان يعني هل
الغرب يتصارع ايضا مع روسيا في جورجيا ام
يعني روسيا هنا هل هي
هي المهاجم ام هي المدافع في جورجيا
اعتقد ان من ما يظهر في الاحداث الان ليس
من مصلحه روسيا ان تكون مهاجما في جورجيا
كون الحزب الحاكم كما اشرنا يتعاطى بشكل
ايجابي مع روسيا على الرغم من ان كل لغته
يعني تتناغم مع القيم الغربيه ومساره
العام يتناغم مع التوجه الى الانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي او محاوله الانضمام الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي لكن من يعني هناك جزء من
الجورجين لا يكتفي بذلك وهو يريد انخراطا
اكبر في وهو متعاطف بالمناسبه مع الاوكران
ومع ما يجري في اوكرانيا وهناك جزء من
الجورجيين ذهبوا الى اوكرانيا للقتال في
الفيلق الاجنبي وبالتالي هناك انقسام في
البلاد وهذا الانقسام تعبر عنه هذه
الاحداث اعتقد ان هناك نقطه مهمه جدا وهي
ان حجم الاحداث حتى هذه اللحظه لا يرقى
الى مصاف ان يحدث انقلابا في المشهد لكن
هذا لا يعني ان التفاعلات المقبله يمكن لا
يمكن ان تنحدر بهذا بهذا الاتجاه الان
الرئيس جورجيا في الولايات المتحده وهي
بالمناسبه تحاول ايضا ايجاد ايجاد صيغه
لحل هذه الاحتجاجات والتراجع عن مشروع
القانون المطروح في البرلمان وهو يعني
بالمناسبه مشروع يسمى بالقانون الروسي لكن
هناك ايضا شبيها له في الولايات المتحده
بعض الدول الغربيه بايجاز لو سمحت باختصار
هل المتظاهرون ايضا برايك محقون فيما
يتعلق بحجم النفوذ الروسي في الحكومه
الجورجيه في هذه المرحله هل حقا تغلغلت
روسيا في الحكم في جورجيا الان ام لا يعني
هذا هذه الشعارات محتجين
او شعارات احتجاجيه من الطبيعي
القول بان روسيا دائما تاريخيا كانت
موجوده في جورجيا ولها هذا النفوس وحتى
وان لم تتدخل بشكل مباشر بمعنى اعطاء
الامراه او توجيه القياده في جورجيا الا
ان وهج حضور روسيا كقوه كبرى في محيط
جورجيا والعلاقات التاريخيه وايضا يعني
افاق المستقبل تبقى حاضره في جورجيا وما
جاء وما جرى في عام 2008 اعتبر درسا في في
جورجيا وبالنسبه للحكم في جورجيا ومن دون
ان يكون ذلك معبرا عنه باملاءات وبامر
فانه من الطبيعي ان ينهج الحكم في جورجيا
باتجاه مرادات روسيا او محاوله عدم
استفزازها او عدم الاصطدام بها على الاقل
شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور محمد سيف الدين كنت
معنا مباشره من باريس
[موسيقى]
بهدفي تدشين صفحه جديده من العلاقات يزور
غدا رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك
فرنسا وسيناقش صنعك وماكرون قضيه ازاله
التوتر بين لندن وباريس اضافه لبحث موضوع
ايقاف قوارب المهاجرين عبر بحر الماتش كما
العربيه رصدت توضع المهاجرين على جانبي
المانش في مدينه كاليه الفرنسيه ودوبرا
البريطانيه من كاليب في فرنسا وعروب عبد
الحق من دوفر السحيلي
تحت هذا الجسر في مدينه كاليل الفرنسيه
الحدوديه مع بريطانيا ينتظر سوريون لحظه
العبور الى حلمهم الانجليزي
يقاومون قسوه الطقس بنار يشعلونها قرب
خيام مبتله يخشون النوم في الليل اكثر من
عبور بحر المونج كي لا تنطفئ النار
ويقتلهم البرد ما فيه غير هالحال طيب ما
عاد يخوفني بحر صحراء اي شيء الوصل لشيء
امان سلام استقرار الشبان الثلاثه قبلوا
الحديث الينا شريطه ان يظهروا ملثمين حرصا
على عدم اخافه اباء وامهات يظنون ان
اولادهم يعيشون نعيما في اوروبا بالنسبه
للبوليس بوليس يعني كل يوم او كل يومين
بيجينا الصبح يعني تقريبا شي الساعه سبعه
الصبح ولا بخلي شيبوظ الخيم وبوخذ كل شيء
بتجيب لنا اياه الامم وبسحب حاله وبطلع
واحيانا شباب هذا الوضع دفع جمعيات فرنسيه
وبريطانيه الى التحرك والاحتجاج على
تصرفات الشرطه التي تضيق الخناقه على
عملهم ايضا
وبدات الشرطه وبلديه بوضع اسلاك وصخور
لمنع المهاجرين من نصب خيامهم
في هذه النقطه الحدوديه في مدينه كاليش
ماليه فرنسا كان المهاجرون ينتظرون حلم
العبور الى بريطانيا داخل خيام جاءت
الشرطه وقتلعتها ووضعت هذه الصخور الثقيله
مكانها لكي تمنعهم من العوده الى هنا لكن
هؤلاء المسؤولين في جمعيات فرنسيه
وبريطانيه جاءوا لازاحه الصخور واعطاء امل
جديد للمهاجرين بامكانيه العبور الى
بريطانيا وان كان عبر قوارب متهالكه في
البحر على الجانب الاخر من الحدود تقف
الزميله عروب عبد الحق لترصد المشهد
اقل ما يمكن وصفها اما برحله موت او رحله
الى المجهول الناجون منها تتلقفهم اجراءات
بريطانيا الجدليه
على طول مسار الساحل الانجليزيه هذا
متحدين امواجا عاتيه احيانا يصل معظم
اللاجئين الى هذه النقطه عبر قوارب الموت
في رحله تستغرق ساعه واربعين دقيقه يضحون
بكل شيء على امل الوصول الى بلاد تعرف
بنظام مساعدات لكن قوانين الهجره المتغيره
سرعان ما تبدد احلامهم فالرود الذي طلب
منا عدم ذكر اسمه الحقيقي يجهل مصيره الى
الان يفضل الانتحار على ان يتم ترحيله الى
رواندا
اذا اجبرت على الذهاب الى رواندا فقد اقدم
على الانتحار لا اريد الذهاب الى هناك لا
استطيع التفسير لكن لا اريد الذهاب الى
رواندا المشكله بحسب حقوقيين يعملون على
مقلوبه من اللاجئين هنا ان مشروع القرار
يضع اللاجئين بشكل تلقائي خارجا نظام
اللجوء
من اكثر الاشياء المحبطه ان ياتي يا اصحاب
المهارات الى هذا البلد و تكون بوجههم
عقبات سواء اذا كانوا طالبي لجوء او طالبي
اعاده توطين لذا اعتقد ان اللاجئين هم
الحل لا يحق للواصلين هنا طلبوا حق اللجوء
او الخروج من دوامات الاحتجاج المعقده ما
يعني وضعهم في طي النسيان في مراكز احتجاز
حتى حل المشاكل القانونيه والاخلاقيه التي
تخلقها قوانين اللجوء البريطانيه من مدينه
مشاهدينا نذهب الان مباشره الى هذه الصور
المباشره اذا من اسرائيل واستمرار اذا
الاحتجاجات ضد التعديلات القضائيه التي
يريدها نتنياهو طبعا اليوم كان هناك عشرات
الالاف تجمعوا في الشوارع طبعا
وكذلك حول مطار بن غوريون في محاوله لمنع
بنيام نتنياهو من السفر الى روما كذلك
طبعا كان وزير الدفاع الامريكي اوستن قد
زار تل ابيب ولكنه لم يغادر المطار بسبب
هذه الاحتجاجات قبل قليل الرئيس
الاسرائيلي القى خطابا ودعا بنيامين
نتنياهو للتراجع عن هذه الاصلاحات
القضائيه في ضوء استمرار الاحتجاجات
اذا عوده الى موضوع زياره ريشيسوناك الى
باريس غدا وكذلك مساله المهاجرين على ضفتي
حول الموضوع معنا باريس حسين قنيبر مراسل
العربيه حسين اهلا بك معنا اذا هناك غدا
في باريس ماذا نتوقع فيما يتعلق بملف
المهاجرين
نعم في الواقع هذه الزياره تكتسي اهميه
خاصه لانها الاولى التي ستكون مناسبه لقمه
فرنسيه بريطانيه منذ العام 2018 بسبب
الازمات المتلاحقه بين البلدين من بينها
اي خروج بريطانيا من الاتحاد الاوروبي ثم
الدور السلبي كما تسميه فرنسا الدور
السلبي لبريطانيا في موضوع انسحاب
استراليا من صفقه الغواصات الفرنسيه كل
ذلك ادى الى توترات ستكون قمه الغد في
الاليزياء مناسبه لطي صفحتها كما ان هذه
القمه تاتي قبل اسبوعين فقط من زياره
سيقوم بها الى فرنسا الملك البريطاني
تشارلز الثالث الذي اختار فرنسا لتكون
وجهه لاول زياره له الى الخارج قبل قليل
صدر عن الرئاسه الفرنسيه بيان جاء فيه ان
القمه الفرنسيه البريطانيه ستكون مناسبه
لتعميق التعاون الوثيق حول اوكرانيا
وضروره الاستمرار في الدعم العسكري لهذا
البلد كي يستعيد سيادته وستكون القمه
مناسبه لمناقشه موضوعات الامن ومكافحه
الارهاب والتطرف والمخدرات والهجره غير
الشرعيه عند الشواطئ الفرنسيه
جديده على ايران ما التفاصيل
نعم فقط لو سمحت لي باشاره اخيره المحور
الرئيسي في القمه الفرنسيه البريطانيه غدا
سيكون الاتفاق بين البلدين لمكافحه الهجره
الشرعيه عند الحدود البحريه بينهما تنفيذا
اولا معاهده
الموقعه عام 2018 وتنفيذا للاتفاق الموقع
في نوفمبر من العام الماضي بين البلدين
والذي وقعته سويلا برايفرمان وزيره
الداخليه البريطانيه مع نظيرها الفرنسي
الجيرال درمنا ستدفع بريطانيا بموجب هذا
الاتفاق مبلغ 72 مليون يورو لفرنسا كي
تزيد هذه الاخيره عدد عناصر الامن
المكلفين بمراقبه الحدود البحريه بين
البلدين من 800 الى 900 عنصر لمكافحه
الهجره غير الشرعيه انطلاقا من فرنسا
بالعوده الى سؤالك حول ايران نعم الناطقه
باسم الخارجيه الفرنسيه قالت اليوم انها
تعتبر ان انما تقوم به ايران من استمرار
دعم
بتزويدها بالمسيرات يعتبر انتهاكا لقرار
مجلس الامن رقم 22 واحد وثلاثين وهي تدعو
ايران الى الوقف الفوري لاي شكل من اشكال
دعم العدوان الروسي على اوكرانيا اضافت
الناطقه الفرنسيه انه بعد ان قام الاتحاد
الاوروبي باتخاذ سلسله عقوبات ضد ايران بل
بفرض سلسله عقوبات على ايران بدءا من
الثاني عشر من ديسمبر من العام الماضي
عندما استهدفت كيانات ايرانيه واشخاص لهم
علاقه بنقل المسيرات الى روسيا بعد هذه
القرارات لا يستبعد ان تتخذ عقوبات
اوروبيه جديده ضد ايران لان ايران مستمره
في تقديم الدعم عبر المسيرات للعدوان
الروسي على اوكرانيا كما قالت الناطقه
الفرنسيه صهيب حسين كليبر مباشره من باريس
ومشاهدينا هذا الان خبر عاجل يبدو ان هناك
حدث اطلاق نار جديد اذا في اسرائيل مراسل
العربيه ينقل اصابه اسرائيليين اثنين
نتيجه اطلاق نار في مقهى في تل ابيب
نوافيكم بالمزيد حول هذه العمليه حول
ورودها نعود الى فرنسا الان مشاهدينا حيث
تستمر الاحتجاجات على تمرير قانون رفع سن
التقاعد بمجلس الشيوخ فيما رد العمال
والموظفون بمزيد من الاضرابات الجديده
ورغم الاحتجاجات والاضرابات يبدو ان خطه
حكومه رئيس الفرنسي امام الماكرون لاقرار
مشروع قانون لتعديل النظام التقاعد المثير
للجدل في طريقها للاقرار اولى هذه الخطوات
جاءت بتمرير مجلس الشيوخ ماده رئيسيه في
مشروع القانون تنصه على رفع سن التقاعد من
62 الى 64 عاما وذلك رغم معركه اجرائيه
حاده مع اليسار 201 من الاعضاء صوتوا
لصالح رفع سن التقاعد مقابل 115 عضوا
صوتوا ضده وينص مشروع القانون ايضا على
زياده مده الاشتراكات المطلوبه في الضمان
الاجتماعي من 42 عاما الى 43 عاما لكي
يحصل المتقاعد على معاشه التقاعدي كاملا
دون اي خصومات برلمانيون يقولون انه من
المتوقع وفقا لخطه الحكومه ان يمرر
البرلمان هذا القانون بحلول السادس عشر من
الشهر الجاري
[موسيقى]
اعلنت منصه تيك توك انه سيتم تخزينه
بياناتي مستخدميها الاوروبيين محليا في
خطوه تهدف الى طمانه السلطات العامه
الاوروبيه في وقت تتصاعد فيه المخاوف
الغربيه المتعلقه بامن البيانات
تتحرك تيك توك لاحتوائه موجه غضب اوروبيه
حيال المنصه مع التصاعد المخاوف المتعلقه
بامن البيانات بدو تخزين بيانات
الاوروبيين محليا في ثلاثه مراكز في
ايرلندا والنرويج بدايه من 2023
بيانات المستخدمين الاوروبيين مخزونه
حاليا في سنغافوره وامريكا
لمواجهه عدم ثقه السلطات الاوروبيه المنصه
تتعهد بعدم نقل بيانات المستخدمين الى
الصين
نائب الرئيس المسؤول عن السياسات العامه
في اوروبا خطتنا الحاليه تبلغ قيمتها 1.2
مليار يورو والتي ستسمح بتقييد وصول
موظفين الى بيانات المستخدمين كما فعلنا
في الولايات المتحده
الضمانات المعلنه تاتي بعد حظر حكومات
ومؤسسات عديده التطبيق من اجهزه موظفيها
اوروبا تعد اكبر سوق للمنصه بمئه وخمسين
مليون مستخدم
التاسع هذا المساء انتهت تذكركم بابرز
عناوينها
يطلب من امريكا واوروبا تغيير نهجها مع
ايران واستون يؤكد على دعم اسرائيل
بمواجهه طهران
امريكا تفرض عقوبات على شبكه صرافه تعمل
بالظل تنقل مليارات الدولارات للنظام
الايراني
[تصفيق]
البيت الابيض يكشف سبب وجود طيارين
اوكرانيين في واشنطن ندرس تركيب اسلحه
امريكيه على مقاتلاتهم الروسيه
في هذه النقطه الحدوديه في مدينه كاليش
ماليه فرنسا كان المهاجرون ينتظرون حلم
العبور الى بريطانيا داخل خيام جاءت
العربيه ترصد عمليات الهجره غير المشروعه
بين فرنسا وبريطانيا على بحر الماتش